[Music]
lifeguards are on duty at pools and
beaches during this hot month of July
including here in New York City of
course and it turns out many of the
city's lifeguards have something very
special in common they got their
training and learned how to swim at one
particular high school Niki batiste is
here with the story
Nicky good morning good morning in an
urban public school a full-sized
swimming pool is something of a rarity
while one school is putting their
unusual asset to good use
changing the lives of young people by
teaching them to save the lives of
others it took all of the courage
seventeen-year-old Johanna Apollo
couldn't muster to make her first dive
ever into this pool three years ago I
was really scared I mean my first diving
was really bad like belly flappin my
whole body heard her bravery is even
more remarkable when you consider the
fact her family had just moved here from
Ecuador how many of you are from
immigrant families so all of you but one
it's only part of what makes this giddy
Grover Cleveland High School swim team
so inspiring how many of you didn't know
how to swim at all you didn't notice
whim at all not knowing how to swim
almost seems like a prerequisite to sign
up here
seventeen-year-old Dino Antoine was
petrified of water the first time I
looked down from like the shallow end to
the deep end and I was like now I'm not
going down there but now he's making a
splash right alongside 17 year old
Fernando Andrade
he transferred here as a freshman just
to swim because pools in this New York
City neighborhood are rare it's scary
because like you think like you dive you
go in you're like oh my god I'm scared
what if I don't come out overcoming fear
what's your first protocol when you see
a victim it's just one of the life
lessons coaches Chris Sullivan and
Felicia Mayer teach when they struggle
and you just tell them you can do it in
in the beginning they don't have like
the confidence the the you know and no
one ever told him about they can you
know to believe in themselves about ten
years ago they had an idea why not train
their swimmers to be lifeguards today
we're gonna go over all the basics of
lifeguard skills but their mission
really serves a dual purpose filling a
local lifeguard shortage and helping
these teenagers build confidence and a
bank account they can make I would say
roughly anywhere from 5,000 to 8,000
dollars a year Grover Cleveland has
certified more than three hundred
working lifeguards in the past decade
dumped kids but they come they travel on
buses for like two hours to get it to
this school the training is tough it's
rigorous it's hard it's very hard but I
think that's that's what you have to do
in order to like save a life you have to
kind of push yourself to that limit so
when we look at this edge this is
considered a higher edge one of the
trickiest things was like getting a
brick from the deep end
and having to like carry it and swim to
the other end that was pretty hard
students must learn CPR
and how to perform a variety of rescues
to become a Red Cross certified
lifeguard I think a lot of them are just
moderate swimmers at first and for them
to get to the level of becoming a
lifeguard can be intense and they work
hard and they get there making the cut
is a milestone how much of it was oh I
want to make some money
oh I want to become more confident Oh
for me I guess it was more of both I
want to be responsible and everything
anymore because I want to help I want my
mom because like he told me oh mama
Fernando's father passed away a few
months ago not long after he told him he
wanted to be a lifeguard and now you are
what do you think you would say - you
think you'd be proud of me he finally
say you're helping out in how it's doing
something good
they newly certified lifeguards are
employed at beaches and pools this
summer that's for when you put it
between your legs
Dino's made about five hundred dollars
so far and says he wants to stick with
it to help pay for college Johanna and
her Grover Cleveland teammate Elsie
Cordero say they feel a great
responsibility sitting in their
lifeguard chairs I feel like with this I
can actually like make the world a
little bit safer when I'm in the chair I
feel like a grown-up people treat me
differently in a way this newfound
respect isn't the only thing these new
lifeguards got the joy of taking home it
felt amazing
it was my first paycheck I was like wow
this is a lot of money for me so far
she's made almost a thousand dollars I
was just planning I guess to save it and
to give some to my parents
but the greatest payoff may be for the
coaches I just watched them and
persevere for all the stuff they have to
do to get to this point it's really it's
really amazing to me they say this isn't
just a swim team
it's a family devoted to saving lives so
three years ago when you were still in
Ecuador could you ever imagine that
you'd be in America lifeguarding making
$14 an hour at 17 know that I couldn't
even you might think Oh sighs anything
even though I have to say what's the
life lesson that everyone walks away
with here well to never give up never
settle don't show yourself in anything
in life coach Sullivan says about 25
students became certified lifeguards
this year the students all say they plan
to go to college
Johanna hopes to be a doctor Fernando
wants to work in sports management and
Dino wants to play in the NBA but says
his back-up plan is to be don't short
yourself though what an amazing program
it really is you know my son became a
lifeguard and this this summer and it's
so true they teach such responsibilities
in those courses as coaches you feel
very good about Sullivan should be very
proud 300 lifeguards in the past decade
sort of as such rigorous training kudos
to them